(sirène de bateau)
- Dans la grisaille qui
enveloppe les minarets des
mosquées, Istanbul se réveille.
Un bateau navigue tranquillement
sur le Bosphore, entre l'Europe
et l'Asie. Les pêcheurs
de sardines du pont Galata
sont déjà à l'oeuvre.
C'est un matin d'hiver
comme tant d'autres
dans la métropole turque.
♪ ♪ ♪
De Byzance à Constantinople,
puis à Istanbul la moderne,
la ville est une des plus
fascinantes de la planète.
Mais pour la grande majorité
de ses 16 millions d'habitants,
la richesse, dans les rues et
les bâtiments, témoigne surtout
du passé et de moins en moins
du présent.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ce jour-là, dès 9 h, dans
un des plus anciens bazars
de la ville, les Stambouliotes
sont nombreux à venir faire
leurs emplettes. Ces marchés
publics sont moins chers
que les épiceries.
BEHIYE ACIKLAP,
cliente retraitée
- Mais même le Bazar est devenu
cher. Avant, on pouvait acheter
tout ce qu'on voulait
avec 100 livres turques;
maintenant c'est impossible.
- Devant ce comptoir d'olives,
on croise Murat Bo
propriétaire d'un restaurant.
Ses dépenses ont explosé
dans la dernière année.
À deux pas de là, Ismail Onuk
vend des sous-vêtements
pour femmes. On pouvait
lui en acheter quatre pour
dix livres turcs il y a
quelques mois. Aujourd'hui,
c'est le double.
ISMAIL ONUK, commerçant
- Ma femme et moi sommes
retraité, mais pour arriver, on
doit être ici et vendre. On n'a
presque plus de vie sociale. On
achète moins de vêtements. On
coupe partout où on peut.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Selon les chiffres officiels,
l'inflation sur un an en Turquie
vient d'atteindre 54 % en
février, c'est 10 fois plus
qu'au Canada. Des études
indépendantes concluent même
à une inflation qui surpasse
100 %. Autrement dit,
la vie est devenue deux fois
plus chère en un an.
- C'est dans les 10 pays
les plus élevés au monde.
C'est un risque pour la Turquie.
- Murat Sagman est un économiste
indépendant réputé du pays.
MURAT SAGMAN,
économiste indépendant
- La cause de l'inflation vient,
d'une part, de l'extérieur,
parce qu'on a une inflation
mondiale, et aussi parce que
nous avons commencé à baisser
nos taux directeurs
de la Banque centrale.
- Mais pourquoi les autorités
ont fait baisser ces taux
alors que pour lutter contre
l'inflation, les experts
s'entendent pour dire
qu'il faut les monter?
- C'est bien sûr contraire
aux théories économiques. Il y a
un but, ça a été de dévaluer
la livre turque pour être
plus compétitive.
- Sauf que la livre turque
a perdu 60 % de sa valeur
en 5 mois face au dollar,
une catastrophe pour un pays
importateur comme la Turquie,
et un choc énorme sur le pouvoir
d'achat des Turques, dont
le salaire moyen ne dépasse pa
10 000 $ par année.
Le Président Recep Tayyip
Erdogan n'en est pas resté là.
- En deux ans, trois directeurs
de banque centrale ont été
congédiés. Bien sûr, ça a
augmenté les risques, voilà.
C'est... La Turquie a besoin
de stabilité économique.
- Au sein de la
la frustration monte face
au président, qui est
au pouvoir depuis 19 ans.
- Avec les salaires, on ne peut pas
payer les loyers. Il y a plein
de difficulté. J'ai peur qu'il
va y avoir, j'espère que non,
une émeute et tout. Donc,
c'est parce que les gens,
ils en ont jusque-là.
- Dans ce décor tout ce qu'il
y a de plus officiel, nous avons
été reçu par un proche
président Erdogan. Akif Cagatay
Kilic est député à Istanbul
pour l'AKP, le parti au pouvoir
depuis 20 ans.
Ce qui a fait mal à l'économie
turque, dit-il, ce sont les
hausses du prix de l'énergie,
l'instabilité au Proche-Orient
et le manque de touristes lié
à la COVID. Et non pas la baisse
des taux d'intérêts.
Pour aider la population,
le président Erdogan a augmenté
de presque 50 % le salaire
minimum en décembre dernier,
ce qui veut donc dire qu'aujourd'hui
une majorité
de Turcs gagnent environ
4250 livres turcs par mois.
Mais c'est à peine l'équivalent
de 5000 $ canadiens par année.
C'est nettement insuffisant
considérant que l'inflation,
elle, augmente encore plus vite.
♪ ♪ ♪
Dans la partie asiatique
d'Istanbul, nous rencontrons
la famille Metin. Soner est
libraire et Hande, sa femme,
travaille en relations
publiques.
HANDE METIN
- Il y a 10 ans, je vous aurais
dit qu'on était dans la classe
moyenne, mais maintenant
l'écart est énorme. Nous fonçons
vers la pauvreté et on ne sait
pas ce qui va nous arriver.
- Sans critiquer son
gouvernement, elle s'inquiète
pour l'avenir de sa fille
et du bébé qu'elle attend.
De plus en plus, nous perdons
espoir dans l'avenir
de notre pays. Nos racines,
nos traditions sont ici. On veut
que nos enfants puissent
y grandir et y être heureux.
- Ege Ogunz voudrait lui aussi
être heureux et croire en son
avenir. Il a 22 ans et travaille
à temps plein dans un café,
au salaire minimum.
Il a arrêté l'école
pour subvenir à ses besoins.
Ege fait partie de ceux qu'on
surnomme la jeunesse Erdogan,
ces Turcs qui n'ont pas connu
d'autres dirigeants et pour qui
entendre que la Turquie a déjà
connu pire ne consolent pas.
Faute d'argent, il n'a jamais pu voyager,
mais sur les réseaux sociaux, il constate à
quel point d'autres Européens
ont une meilleure vie.
Mais, il le sait, d'autres
jeunes, à quelques centaines
de kilomètres de chez lui,
sont encore plus malchanceux
aujourd'hui. La guerre
en Urkraine risque fort
d'aggraver la crise économique
turque. Le pays s'attendait
à une saison touristique record
cet été.
- La majorité du tourisme vient
des pays russes, Ukraine, etc.
Et c'est pour ça... c'est
important aussi pour nous. Nous
avons beaucoup d'importations,
d'exportations avec la Russie.
- Murat Sagman conclut sur une
note positive : le pays, habitué
aux crises, a l'habitude
de se relever rapidement.
Les 86 millions de Turques
veulent y croire. Croire
en une vie meilleure avec assez
d'argent pour au moins rêver.